in this quick video i wanted to run
through the division universe at a high
level view showing where each addition
to the franchise has been set within the
overall timeline
exact dates stop being used relatively
early on and very little coming from
official sources have referenced these
initial dates
as a result this has led to a small
amount of speculation particularly
around what year the outbreak has
occurred
however for the purpose of this video
i'll be working with the officially
released information we have until it
finally stopped being given out with the
rest of the information it will be based
on the most likely scenario given on how
the events are playing out
from here we'll see where the yet to be
released edition slot in based on what
we know so far
[Music]
[Music]
all division media has been released on
the following dates with more still to
be confirmed
i'll be running through each of them in
this order but as you'll soon see this
has very little to do with their actual
place within the storyline
the original division story begins on
the 6th of january 2016 with the second
wave of division agents being activated
by the president
the first wave was activated over two
weeks prior but have since gone mia
over time we would learn of how
everything started with gordon amherst
releasing the dollar flue in abel's
department store in new york city on
black friday the 27th of november 2015.
from here dates start to get a little
bit murky but from the events happening
at other media releases it's likely that
the storyline that plays out in the game
leads us to somewhere around late
february early march
it is early december when april kalahar
witnesses her husband bill's death in
front of the sequent biotech group in
manhattan
it has been a week since the virus was
released and authorities are still
struggling with how to deal with it
april's pursuit of the truth has her
following clues all over new york city
until eventually on january 7th she
learned of warren merchant's whereabouts
in the northern side of the dark zone
in early may the shd network goes down
automatically recalling all division
agents to the nation's capital
washington dc
as the story is still playing out and no
in-game dates been given since its
release it's anyone's guess as to what
the dates are currently in game
however the last states that can be
pinpointed is that sometime around june
the true sons launched a chemical attack
on the castle sediment
and in july division agents had
recovered prison alice's suitcase with
him disappearing shortly after followed
by the invasion of the black tusk
so given the current weather it's likely
that we're sitting somewhere between the
end of july and september
in early february agent aurelio diaz
travels from his home in dc to assist in
the fight for new york city
several months later he leaves new york
in pursuit of ike ronson an agent who
has left some civilians to die at the
hands of a hostile faction
when he catches up to ronson who is now
met up with april callahar and ann arbor
he soon discovers that ronson has gone
rogue and is working for the black tusk
an attack on the facility is inbound but
diaz in april managed to escape
parting ways april makes it to dc in
late may
in late march agent dunn's partner is
killed by a black tusk operative known
only as mantis
dunn makes it his goal to hunt her down
on his way to philadelphia he meets and
joins up with agents heather ward and
brian johnson
in early may they catch up with mantis
and manage to capture her however she is
assassinated by a black tusk sniper
before they are able to extract any
information from her
at this stage the sh network has been
down for a little while now and on their
watches show the coordinates of
washington dc
they make the choice to head towards the
signal and by mid to late may they are
looking down across the capital
the hearts on fire audiobook actually
starts around 16 months before the
release of the virus
where melanie hoskins an experienced
firefighter paramedic is being recruited
by the division
after eventually agreeing she would
undertake the 12-month training process
with the virus being released only four
months after a completion one of her
first tasks is to deal with a new
hostile group called the cleaners who
are causing chaos throughout the city
it isn't overly clear as to where the
end of the story takes place but it's
still very early on in the conflict so i
would place this somewhere around mid to
late january
the story around this group of childhood
friends who have all taken their own
paths over the years spent half of its
time talking about events that happened
several decades beforehand
the overall span of the story seems
relatively short and focuses on times
where the hyena council is still well
established we also see odissa sawyer
who has already taken a step back from
the division after losing her leg my
best guess would be to place the events
of these few days somewhere between
early april and late may
we have very little to go on with thomas
parrott's recruited novel while it
starts with myra kanhai trying to rejoin
the u.s navy just after the outbreak the
bulk of the story happens many months
later after the death of president ellis
so the earliest estimate i can give
would be sometime after july
compromised is another novel from parrot
that continues the story of recruited
as this isn't going to be released until
december this year it's tough to say
what time period this will be covering
nothing official has been released about
heartland at this point while there's
been a lot of leaked information like i
said earlier i'll be trying to keep this
to what has been released by ubisoft or
as played out in the story
though what we can see so far from the
image alone is the weather
so given that this is likely to be
playing out in the us and that there are
leaves all over the ground appearing
like it's in the autumn months it's
looking to be based around september to
november
resurgence another yet to be released
game however with this one we've been
given an indication of where this will
span across the story
at this stage we've been told that this
will cover from the point of the first
wave agents all the way up to the events
of the division two unfortunately this
is all we have for now it's possible
that resurgence may even go further into
the story timeline beyond the division
two but for now we'll just have to wait
and see
so there it is a high-level view on how
each of the stories overlap in the
division universe timeline
i've had a live document of this running
for a while now as it helps me with
research towards certain topics
i actually have a far more detailed
version of this which features all of
the factions and characters within but
this document is an absolute mess with
lines and crossovers all over the place
i'd really like to release something on
this but i honestly have no idea where
i'd start i can barely read it myself
these days
if you are unfamiliar with any of these
specific stories i've placed links
throughout the video but i'll also
include them in the description
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch you on the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank
uh